يعني ما اضيقها لولا فسحه الامل هي تلك
الحياه التي يبدو ان طفلين من
جنديرس قد حظي بها مره اخرى رغم ان كل
يعني التوقعات
والاراء قالت بان الاحياء تحت الانقاذ في
جنديرس لدينا معلومات جاري التاكد من
صحتها بان فرق الدفاع المدني تمكنت من
انتشال طفلين على قيد الحياه في بلده
جنديرس التي يعني شهدت اكبر نسبه من
الدمار على مستوى سوريا ايضا ليله امس كان
هناك انقاذ لطفلين في مبنى في جبله في
مبدا رحاوي في جبله الذي قتل في هذا
المبنى لوحده اكثر من 40 شخص بفعل الزلزال
يعني رغم انه الاعمال يعني تكاد تنتهي لكن
بين الفينه والاخرى يعود هذا الامل ويتجدد
من تحت وكاننا يعني امام معجزات حقيقيه
تحدث فيلم بلدين في سوريا وفي تركيا وكانه
هناك قدره الهيه تقول لا تياسوا ولا
تفقدوا الامل وهو ما يشجع طبعا فرقه
الدفاع وفرق الانقاذ لتكثيف عملياتها كما
يجري الان في جنديرس وايضا في مركز مدينه
جبله تابعه اللاذقيه وايضا في مركز مدينه
اللاذقيه حيث فرق
الانقاذ والبحث تسارع بحثا عن ناجين يتجدد
الامل بالعثور عليهم